nous ne pouvons pas j'allais dire que
parler de l'immigration de la
répartition liée à l'absence de
politique migratoire rappelle que nous
avons des livrets plus de 270 000 titres
de séjour en 2019 nous allons avoir
cette année plus de 120 000 demandeurs
de l'asile nous avons un problème de
politique migratoire nous avons un
problème de gestion de la migration il y
a d'ailleurs un excellent rapport du
Sénat qui me semble être en train
d'inspirer le gouvernement qui a été
fait par le président de la commission
des lois François de Noël buffet et qui
par exemple propose de simplifier
clarifier la processus de délivrance des
autorisations de séjour des contentieux
et de l'exécution réelle les obligations
de quitter le territoire français sans
politique migratoire
volontariste nous aurons un jour les
votes de la Suède et peut-être je le
regrette dimanche les votes de